disney's newest live-action movie
cruella is packed with fashion
intrigue and some truly outlandish
performances
and of course it's also filled with
small details that only the attentive
fan can catch
here some you might have missed toward
the beginning of the film or posing as a
maid to rob hotels
estella gets distracted and watches a
scene from an old film playing on the
television
the movie is alfred hitchcock's lifeboat
about a group of people stranded in the
middle of the ocean awaiting rescue
the scene highlights actress tallulah
bankhead in her role as constance
bursting into a fit of hysterical
laughter after losing
everything she valued in life it's a
haunting laugh
full of desperation and madness the same
kind of feelings a cellar will be hit
with later on
fittingly disney animator mark davis
said in an interview with the los
angeles times
that bankhead was actually one of his
inspirations when he was creating the
original cruella
as she watches the scene estella is also
wearing a name tag that reads norma
this references another hitchcock
character from the movie psycho
norma who's heard but not seen in the
movie is the domineering mother of
norman bates
her influence on her cern causes him to
develop a murderous alter ego
though stella doesn't become a killer
like norman bates her cruella persona
overwhelms her true identity
and jeopardizes her sanity similar to
how norman's murderous ways overtake him
as events unfold it's revealed that a
stellar's hatred of dalmatians
stems from witnessing three canines push
her mother off a cliff to her death
even prior to this event though black
spots are a constant nuisance in a
stellar's life
we see her splattered with blobs of
black ink at school
and her headmaster fills her school
reports with black dots
to mark her demerits before finally
expelling her from school
the three dalmatians in cruella are also
referential to the greek myth of
cerberus
a three-headed dog that guards the gates
of the underworld the entryway of the
baroness's manor appropriately named
hell hall
briefly shows a carving of three dog
heads this motif seen at the top of the
home's entrance
reinforces the greek legend additionally
drawing cruella we learn the name of
only one of the three dalmatians
genghis this is evidently a nod to
genghis khan
a historical figure famed for his
savagery and ruthlessness in battle
makes the animals even more menacing all
these elements foreshadow both the
hound's hellish
nature and estella's future relationship
with the breed
although it's never stated plainly
estella's real last name is miller
as seen in the liberty london employment
letter jasper gives her for her birthday
when her birth certificate is revealed
we learn that her actual name is the
honorable estella von hellman
the certificate also includes her
birthday as august 7th
1952. since the majority of the movie
takes place in 1977
that means estella just celebrated her
25th birthday
at the moment some written information
helped offer a clearer timeline of
events
thanks to her birth date we know estella
was 12 years old when she began
attending private school
getting expelled after just one year we
also know from the newspaper headlines
splashed on screen
that cruella begins to upstage the
baroness on november 30th
1977 meaning she'd been employed at the
fashion house for fewer than four months
before she started wreaking havoc and
although the house of baroness may not
be a real-life fashion house the liberty
london department store which initially
employs zestella
is completely genuine and has been in
business since 1875.
throughout cruella there are several
callbacks and references
to the original 1961 animated feature
101 dalmatians
for starters estella has a schoolmate
named anita darling
her first name is obviously a nod to
anita radcliffe
from the 1961 flick but her full name is
a reference to the movie as well
it's the first thing cruella de vil says
in the movie
another call back happens when horace
sees a woman working her afghan hound
and asked jasper whether he's ever
noticed that people tend to look like
they're dogs
this is a direct reference to the first
scene of 101 dalmatians
where people walking with their dogs
bear a striking resemblance to their
pets
one of the dog walkers is a woman
dressed in brown who's walking are
afghan hound
exactly like the woman horus sees in
cruella additionally the car that
cruella steals in this movie
is the same model that cruella drives in
both the animated movie
and the 1996 live-action film starring
glenn close
specifically it's a panther deville and
serves as an inspiration for cruella
in choosing her last name devel he
spelled devil by his pronounced
veal the last scene of cruella sets up
the elements for the beginning of the
101 dalmatians film
at the end cruella gives anita and the
baroness's lawyer roger one dalmatian
puppy each
the boxers they come in declare their
names to be pongo and pedita
which are the names of the puppies in
the original story additionally cruella
and anita are former schoolmates
in the original film and the one year
they spend together before cruella's
expulsion
just make that statement technically
true the ending of cruella also lays a
foundation for roger's future antagonism
towards cruella by adding the narration
roger always blamed me for getting him
fired
as the credits roll we hear roger sing
the original cruella de vilson
written by melville levin rogers
apartment in cruella is also an
impressive duplicate of the bachelor pad
roger inhabits in the animated movie
from 1961.
it features a disarray of bookshelves a
cello and a clock above the fireplace
covered by a hat
exactly as seen in the 60s film as to
the logic of why cruella would one day
try to skin the puppies that she gifted
to her friends
especially given that she appears to
enjoy the company of old dogs at the end
of the movie
it's anyone's guess check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one